yo welcome to the on stroke comes a four
or Rockefeller
yeah right we're doing rocky just number
four I'm supposed to take Gilbert that's
Joe that's Dan oh hey hey we will be
doing plenty of thing before we will be
talking about our honest trailer for
Rock for some old insights behind the
scenes and if you stick around to the
end maybe some cut stuff I don't know if
we have a gym do we're gonna cut jokes
[Music]
he clearly has CTE and is struggling
with brain damage not change the rocket
rocky yeah rocky definitely sound itself
punch-drunk is no just a little
punch-drunk don't worry about him he's
just always out of it you know what kind
of a punches to be fair he was not the
brightest bulb even before he started
boxing yes sure no no that's fair this
is the first rocky movie we've ever done
yeah yeah which is crazy weird
no it's discussion about what we should
do and we were like should we do all the
ones and we're like this one has
everything it's got it all and also you
know the freaking Drago back for creed
too
so makes it let's do the Drago one and
I'm sure they'll bring little club' Lang
jr. little clubber beber Creed 3 little
clever and Tommy minigun yeah I think
paulista might still be around
Wow maybe didn't he die in Rocky Balboa
yeah he's dead dead yeah stupid didn't
we bring back the ghost and Mickey goes
to makea polian gareki buh buh yeah
Mickey was a ghost okay flashback flash
and his Paulie dead yeah Wow
not after rocky he's dead but the actor
himself Burt young is alive and whoa-oh
I'm just saying it's not out of the
question on it to him back yes or his
souls in the robot yeah well he just
went full singularity oh yeah yeah could
say he came inside the robot say that or
the Orson knew
robot that is offspring by oh there's
one crate - they really drop the ball of
faith Holly but yeah even if it's not
like an maybe it's an AI maybe Michael B
Jordans like yo Paul instead of Siri so
this film it's got a little bit of
everything it's got a well it's got a
lot of montages that's do you know
political commentary yep
some some of the rocky action we've come
to know and love which is like truly the
worst technical boxing of all time yes
they're doing oh man it's like sorry Joe
like wrestling but with hands their hand
wrestling wrestling no yeah no one ever
taught him about put your guard up yeah
no never put your hands in front of your
face right use your chin rock if you put
your hands in front of your face they'll
be in front of your eyes and you can't
see your opponent yeah so these aren't I
mean they qualify as sports movies who's
obviously boxing as a sport and they're
always like underdog from the bottom you
know ends on a freeze-frame yeah but the
way it depicts boxing I don't know if
people even say Raging Bull is like a
like a accurate boxing movie even that
one I guess like real boxing is just not
very cinematic because it's a lot of
just like is old boxing used to be much
better but now boxing now is like - guys
we're getting paid but a twenty million
dollar at prestige I don't mean like a
heavyweight boxing now yeah not almost -
guys you're getting paid twenty million
dollars who are doing who are protecting
their careers so they'll go out and most
of the ones I've seen in the last 15
years are - multimillionaires who go out
and just protect themselves got 12
rounds and try to win by decision and
set up the rematch or the link even more
money it's it's by the way totally
understandable I would rather get paid
twenty million dollars and not get hurt
so I get that yeah you know you
shouldn't be boxes well no you're doing
Adrian does a good job at the boxing
with the early yeah I mean that's pretty
that single deal awesome well it's like
it's like football in movies like I
don't like real football I really like
movie football moving football's just
like here's all the badass stuff and
never like we're standing around yeah
the commercial movie boxing is kind of
the same yeah yeah I don't know I mean
this movie is it's weird because people
didn't even like it when it came out it
got really bad reviews they're like oh
god everyone's rolling their eyes at it
and like I think I went from
ironically liking it to not really
liking it because it's just fun like
it's not long it's not it doesn't take a
lot of your time to re-watch rocky for
tightening the F F F through the
montages I know sacrilege but the end
the movie and Selma those are important
I know but I'm just saying the original
movie itself is maybe an hour and then
the rest is flashbacks and montage
that's true passport there's no easy way
out man there is no easy way out there's
no shortcut home yeah giving in can't be
wrong yeah yeah but yeah it's a weird
feeling because he lost bill conti for
this one so Vince Nicola scores it
instead it's just weird and there's
still some survivor so while they replay
a beggar yeah there's another survivor
so on yeah
which did not hit the height to fire the
tiger Oh burning hard is no yeah no I
the tiger yeah so yeah I mean this the
it's great pump up film if you've seen
three Rocky's you've probably seen the
fourth - but I mean I think it's really
amplified by the villain by Drago Drago
is what probably his best adversary of
all of the whole series and then just
the fact that Rocky's like a pseudo use
change but could joy like that speed
could change and the fact that like now
like at the time there was still
communism and Soviet Russia was a thing
and yeah it would be another I think
four years before Paul the Berlin Wall
like it's you got a
you saw back in that context Oh it'd be
like Michael B Jordan winning and be
like I see a lot of kata you know
different after all I just like all
right yeah right you're right yeah silly
movie but a lot of fun so we had fun
doing it hope you had fun watching it
let's play that commentary wait we're
out we're in commentaries now all right
let's watch the damn thing actually
found a way we do is here already let's
get pumped by pulling an 80s classic out
from the honest trailer vault I love all
done for good Roger Moore has walked
away from the Bond franchise and
Superman 3 proved were pretty tired of
comic book movies at least we still have
rocky seriously where could they
possibly go from Rocky 3 make their kids
fight each other
that'd be dumb I feel like we an early
draft of the script was like to suck
goofiness froggy for it was the
perspective was a little too fawning
over it right I feel like that's a
recent development at the time and be
like uh I can't believe they're making
another Rocky movie and we tried to
actually stick with and I think we only
violate it once of like the the point of
view on strobes would have if we were
doing this in 1984 84 we would have been
very upset that 85 5 I think is 85 but
the 1985 that we were still here doing
in Rocky movies it's there's something
so interesting too about thinking back
about that time we're like now that if
we were into like Rocky movies were like
jock movies like they weren't nerd
movies and here we are moving nerds
we're like Oh Rocky but yeah people who
like Rocky would have been kicking our
ass back then that's true like all those
macho action movies like shorts Nagar
Stallone
that's Seagal like all that stuff like
nerds didn't like that however I posit
that we're honest trailers launched in
the 80s we would have made our names
doing those movies and not the nerd
movies because those were the popular
ones so yeah no one would've watched our
last starfighter no nobody would
cared about our last starfighter in
Australia so in a way this I think this
would have been exactly what we would
have done yeah if we were around back
then I mean what they did I mean when
they were back then
yes 1985 when this trailer was made
alright keep going
someday woman that wrote it you've seen
Rocky punch Apollo Creed
you've seen him punch mr. t now get
ready for rocky Balboa's biggest
challenge yet
punching communism in the face with a
Russian murders his worst enemy slash
best friend he'll seek revenge in a
showdown so epic it requires a training
montage another training montage
and the third bonus montage of rocky
thinking about his past
training montages no easy way out is the
most underrated Rockets on the hall I
agree man it's like a dream inside of a
dream is there a word for that nah but
it'll take more than so pause I guess
what we could talk about that in this
section but it's like the the training
styles the different training styles
yeah
the way they're they're contrasted with
each other it's like rocky did it like
the natural way like he's just out in
the snow and just like lifting growing a
beard
lifting logs you're gonna beard whereas
Drago is also just doing normal workouts
what he's hooked up to like graphs and
it's it's intimated very heavily that he
is using steroids
oh I mean they literally put a needle in
him at one point yeah yeah it's yeah
first of all Stallone 1984 like maybe
found a needle in that haystack yeah but
like four times yeah I guess you're
right the steroids think does does tip
the balance but like nothing track I was
- he was seemed very advanced he was
running on a treadmill doing the same
thing and he was punching a bag but then
like numbers would go I'm like oh clip
boards yes but you're right this was the
like East German swim team and like it's
the first steroid scandals were
happening oh yeah then yeah because he
was supposed to be a pure amateur you
know like a pure ya know I think they're
trying to show like the the rugged
boldness of the singular American spirit
versus like this um this giant room of
evil Soviet scientists like all gathered
together to write make one man a machine
yeah something something point is none
of us have seen well have you seen Creed
- yet yeah yeah let's see it's morning
well I hope that they can tonight I hope
that they continue that and have them
you know different types I hope I mean
Drago Sun is connected to machines that
clearly don't do it yeah I want this to
connect to what's a documentary that
just came out about the Russian doping
scandal Icarus yeah I want this
we were also talking about how this is
why we like to do the retro ones
sometimes because we've done things like
Batman and Robocop that were not out of
the vault because they're like we have a
modern thing willing to compare it to
but this had so much old stuff that we
could refer to yeah but the idea the
concept of inception being something
that we take for granted but like how
much that's permeated like culture the
just like the everything around it like
yeah I mean look that word predates the
movie but I feel like the way that we
use it especially it like another layer
deeper to like a fantasy or like
Inception like Inception would that's
kind of snuck up on us it's been
incepted into our heads if you will it
has and that's why nolan is the greatest
film maker of all time he put that in
there and a level-4 yeah Mike's rolling
around in the hallway Krakow a Soviet
punching machine who's bewildered by our
strange American ways like showgirls and
electricity and all overboard with
fennel a dumbfounded he was contrary
words only 46 in the whole movie to be
exact and somehow this undefeated gold
medalist has taken our heroes by
surprise why don't they take Experian
pause ha let's talk about this because
right we really suss this out like you
Joe the Olympics were in 84 yeah I
didn't the Soviets boycott these
actually you're right or we boycotted
them you don't remember it was in LA and
I don't I don't think they participated
that said if you're a gold medalist and
an amateur champion they yeah they're
probably some tape of you super-sized
just look at him like yes the physical
evidence alone eight foot four yeah I
Apollo I feel like if he is sure if he
doesn't watch every match but that'd be
weird to that you're like a champion
boxer and you he's reliving his own
glory days why wouldn't he see who else
is out there and who's relaxing and
stuff like that yeah you at that point
in your career I feel like you'd be a
boxing nerd Yeah right you're like look
at all these up
comer's well the movie like plays it
both ways part of it is Apollo saying
like I'm still as good as I ever was
like I you know people call me oh I'm
not washed-up like that's one side but
then they start to fight he's beating up
Apollo and they're like what are you
doing this is supposed to be an
exhibition match like what part of you
looking at him said this guy's not
taking this seriously yeah it's like
what was he was he trying to do an
exhibition match or was he out there to
prove that he was the best cuz it was I
think they just kind of they had the
script for Rocky 3 and you know with
Hulk Hogan that was supposed to and is
there something that's supposed to be
there about like Americans are just real
cocky and we don't really take anything
seriously cuz even leading up to the
match like they just treat Drago like
[ __ ] we're like very cruel to them and
also that's been Apollo we the
characters I remember I remember reading
that press conference it was crazy yeah
but yeah they're just jerks to the to
the guy and they're like I just want the
box just talking smack to him yeah I
think that fits with Apollo I mean he's
always had the America trunks like he's
he's kind of supposed to read as like a
like Muhammad Ali on steroids which is
like a type of boxer so you know but he
is a stand-in for US foreign policy I
think I just like there's a disconnect
between Apollo's managers and Apollo I
think for two reasons
100% yeah his managers are like he went
trunk shopping again and hat shop and
make sure it matches with James Brown
he's supposed to be doing bad work like
an exhibition I guess boy he's gonna die
forcing rocky to fly all the way to
Russia in order to lift things know and
chop down trees sure he could have done
all that in Lake Tahoe
but yeah suck it you dirty commie trees
like a Spartan whatever
shoo cuz Paulie is still getting bullied
happy birthday tell her Buck's her
husband not to box with his face it's a
shot of new life with some updated
geopolitics futuristic talking robot be
we I think we all agreed that they
should follow up the Happy Birthday song
with Paulie the robots Happy Birthday
song which is just happy birthday Polly
I loved the movie for 30 seconds turns
into like short circuits less weird sila
it's like the music completely changes
and editing pace and it's just like it
turns into like this techno like this is
about a robot now this whole movie is
gonna be about this robot happy birthday
Polly
happy birthday Pauly's like it's like
the glue Beauty shots of like as like as
as this a different movie did we take a
turn to the robot a sparring partner is
it gonna be the robot the Polly's robot
they I mean it's been picked apart to
death but like it just bears repeating
that at the beginning of this movie the
robot is introduced and by the end it's
Polly's love interest but there's no
middle yeah we don't see them what
happens in between yeah so obviously
there is a difference between Stallone
the very talented man and his character
rocky who is a very simple from below
flow below but it seems like Stallone
wrote rocky for as
firstly there were few had a robot I
don't know well as we say matches which
we're gonna play the rest of the clip
but it's like he he I think has an
autistic son write it Stallone I don't
know or he he put in this robot because
it was something that that was used to
help children with autism and they could
relate and it could like make them feel
safe and comfortable and then they could
integrate into their family that's
wonderful that's wonderful and that's
one way to use the robot yes the other
way is to give your old single grouchy
hype man a sexbot that was designed for
his two children that he turns into his
geisha the ratio of set up to pay off
what the robot is very low yeah
there's really not enough robot but it's
not it is it sparked a thousand fan
theories and fan fictions and I suspect
that won't stop to this very day
no maybe will help provide it god I hope
it's in Creede to send us your favorites
yes anyway so Polly has not demonstrated
any proclivity with you know robotics or
computer program yeah nor has the robot
I mean maybe it's like her where it
likes scanned him and then it's like she
will become what Polly needs it to be do
you like this voice better yeah or did
Paul II actually seduced and charmed and
did she fall in love with him did he
guess like the robot to be like you have
a lady gender now like there's a hole
behind this movie as we're saying an
entire film just forced a personality on
the robot I think it basically is just
ex machina they're like slowly following
each other around the mansion like
giving meaningful glances just like in a
robe doing Oscar Isaac stuff like robot
like arm goes to the wall and like all
the lights changes like Rocky's
listening to everything we do you need
to help me
you think he's like really twitchy and
is that why it goes to Russia because
he's starting to get nervous about the
sexpot yeah hey you bet out of your room
snake Mumbai if you're ready to see the
Soviet Union crumble one punch at a time
but you can't wait long enough to watch
the load help our brave Mujahideen
friend so far in case you don't know
that's joking the trip Rambo 3 is about
Rambo going to Afghanistan to team up
with the Mujahideen eulogist freedom
fighters against the Soviet Union it's
dedicated to them it is dedicated to the
Mujahideen hooked up in the 80s by Uncle
Sam you know times weird I'm crazy yeah
it's interesting yeah cuz like you know
these days what we care about changes
every you know 48 hours every day cycle
but that was you know that they were the
godless communists and here were these
brave religious freedom fighters who
just wanted to practice their religion
that way we were like all right Reagan's
like give them the bomb so and it made
its way into pop culture and then we
forgot about them yeah Wilson's war is a
great yeah that's a great great movie
about that exact thing and Philip
Seymour Hoffman
rest in peace one of my favorite
performances of his is the guy who has
like spent his entire career or at least
like you know however many years working
like that beat and when it's over was
like going to Charlie Wilson he's just
like well no what are your plans and
he's like well what do you mean we're
done and he's just like okay just like
the movie it's like yeah really yeah
okay let's see how that works out yeah
it's such a great movie watch that hole
it's worth it era I told my dad
my dad has a weird way of looking at
movies in TV sometime like when I told
him out Breaking Bad he was like is that
that thing about that meth dealer I
don't give a crap about that guy he's a
criminal
I'm not watching the show and so I told
him about Charlie Wilson's War I was
like I just watched it it's really good
and he was like hello Charlie Wilson
that son of a [ __ ] yeah it's kind of
about that Maleficent she gave that poor
girl the poison apples now I'm in the
sinking place all right let's keep going
with the United States and gets away
with it
wait no I actually have I think about
that I have a sort of distant relative
who I was talking to who refused to see
Tonya Harding hi Tonya refused to see I
Tanya she could just not forgive
Tonya for what you did I was like but
it's like about that you get to hear the
whole story it's like now I just can't
see why anyone would the mob looks like
goofy and dumb as much as it makes it
look cool yeah yeah he just doesn't like
criminality on screen or on the streets
yeah is he a vigilante maybe it's maybe
it makes sense yeah yeah it would have
to revolve around model trains all right
all right
and sinnin send an onion articles about
Trump those are six yeah potent brew
yeah all right interesting dude okay
yeah you imagine the future of Russia is
still the bad guy in Hollywood is still
making Rocky movies yeah what am I
saying
Willie the sci-fi to that Austrian dude
oh you're gonna be Australian babe yeah
there was a pause we we went about pated
whether to joke that he we thought he
was Australian right was that right cuz
we said I think maybe accidentally or
maybe just because we had to get this
done very quickly there's a take where
John says Austria
dude yeah and we debated keeping him
saying Australian and this may be the
influence of the audience on us we had
to weigh how funny we thought it was
that John that the epic voice in this
time would call him Australian because
he is just familiar yeah Conan and how
badly we did not want to get well
actually to death from him saying like
oh you made a mistake so enjoying our
Thanksgiving holidays and decided to go
with Austrian yeah that joke went away
that joke went bye-bye yeah sorry to to
rob the you mister their favorite thing
we pay enough for our legitimate
mistakes that are beyond making ones on
purpose for humor well you know I I'm
waiting for people to be like you know
what what what what worked out with his
friends from Afghanistan I'm sure you
guys will find if you know anything
about history that those were not good
people and they'll just totally miss the
joke Oh like when when I called a world
war one the prequel to world war two Oh
God I think it's pretty clear if you
look carefully that one moment takes
place in World War one but Spencer we
didn't realize that his eye was like
that because Laurie Strode punked him in
the eye was a it was a hangar let's
everyone talk about only this forever
we got her face are e that was on me we
met we missed something we didn't make a
connection no Dan we're omnipotent we
know all things about all things sorry
yeah let's keep going sorry I just
that's okay so and toot your own horn no
it's the case of when it's everyone has
these of like we have no ideas and like
this is the stupidest I've I didn't want
to say it because it's so stupid
that's not funny that's a shame it's
really fun to say
but I think that's that was my turn cuz
yeah I know you've had it I've had it of
the joke where we can't think of
anything and everyone's just like well
the stupidest I think I can think of is
this stupid thing yes and it just
happens there was a moment cuz we were
all just silently like staring at the
script on our individual laptops and
then just quietly from the couch comes
rambamboo I didn't even realize that it
was a play on his names at first I just
like the script will figure out what it
means it sounds funny sometimes things
just sound funny better need to make
sense Dane yeah bonus that it did yeah
keep bambo Rob the robot ain't gonna be
no rematch now pause that is positive
act to gene Shalit where this sent us
down like a weird oh so that's not gene
Shalit other famous mustachioed eighties
personality yeah I can't remember his
name
but this is a fine artist like a yeah
many right big like painter yeah who was
active in the 80s and 90s who I think it
was was a rocky to that ends when it
turns into a painting 3 yeah like he
painted that and he's famous for doing
these kind of impressionist ik
renderings of athletes and rocky put him
in the movie like put him in Rocky 3 and
put him in this one so just pausing and
saying hey that guy kind of looks like
gene Shalit led us down a weird thing
cuz we googled his name and it was like
all about his art career in his like
he's just a famous accomplished very
accomplished famous painter and the guy
with the super weird like that great
ring announcer NASA's rocky 4 so fun
fact
thank you I think that's the one part I
forgot to catch us that's where we break
the
version of the fact that this was
happening in 1984 he wouldn't have known
when it ends I looked it up actually the
the it was widely acknowledged that the
beginning of the end of the Soviet Union
had begun already in 1985 so I believe
that the epic voice writing was on the
berlin wall would have recognized that
this was more about the end of a mutual
modernization was already a problem in
the Soviet Union you're right and so if
they weren't like this movie wouldn't
have been the way it is if they were
still really a threat right exactly this
this was this was the mainstream
acknowledgment of the fact that the ice
was cracking on the so in the Cold War
and so I actually believe it or not stop
don't lean forward to stop you're
leaning stop it I looked I stopped it I
looked into this it was no stop it's we
did the research five years
we did it guys we all broke this orbit
Trump in the eye with a hammer
as a society we got him okay let's let's
wrap this up
walkies eyes open why not
so wait if rocky Pali and Adrienne are
all in Russia who's watching the kids
[Music]
that's your favorite Joseph eight to
read they'd read that is now canonically
the first time honest trailers did that
the trophy ironclad don't tell us
anything
yeah yeah it's back when and is this
epic voice guys dad or has he been in
the booth for a long he's into this game
yeah I think the voice is the last thing
to go first the body then the brain
everyone knows that all right yeah yeah
we have some billions he makes probably
have sex with it in ten years I'll be
doing it too maybe story
Captain America white Tyson what The
Rock is cooking you guys might not be
ready for that joke but your kids will
love it big red in Soviet Russia
communism fight in technology the day in
my head I think the cinnamon in Soviet
Russia communism fights you just adding
insult to injury he was barely dead in
1985 I did not see that or I would have
fought to put that in come like a very
twisted new version of not a great plan
another great we must do overlooked that
one yeah Wow okay
or Soviets zero yeah
Drago Slayer enter animate the
non-americans angry goes this is what
we're fighting the comics for kids a
swimming pool three dogs and a magic TV
not plugged into anything like oh yeah
yeah that's fine good times yes this is
the best possible movie to do a retro
for like there's so much to be able to
comment on cuz the hind sang joke the
hindsight joke is fine it's see the
funny bit yeah and there's a million
different things you could do with this
one yeah this was fun yeah yeah five
years ago I don't know if this would
have been this money from their vault
but just and everything else right now
it's just like it's it's too funny yeah
just because we are now seeing an actual
political it's now swinging it's like we
didn't realize it as a pendulum
yeah it's nothing seems to be swinging
the other way which I didn't know is it
possible but here we go
here we are well I'm excited to see
people complain if creed to like touches
on any of this I'm excited to see people
complain that they put politics well I'm
excited to see if rainbow 7 that's like
I guess that was wrong about you maybe
we should put together first light oh
yeah oh man good first alone he still
got he's still doing it you know he he
really he does ground the Rocky movies I
think if it was if he wasn't just such a
lovable doofus that those movies would
know the first 30 minutes are just like
him being a goof yeah and like you you
end up caring about it by the end of it
I like where I like Rocky Balboa me too
I think he's legitimately good and Rocky
Balboa and Creed yeah we make fun of him
cuz he's easy to make fun of but the for
the worst rocky movie to still be what
rocky thirty years ago yeah that's
pretty bad
I mean I feel like a lot of people would
have not stuck with he's a lovable oaf
and their ego would have gotten in the
way and he would have become just like
some awesome like all-american like real
charming like charismatic badass but
like he keeps rocky just nope he's
he's a sweet dummy yeah all the way
through even even to Crete it's
impressive
yeah well he's easy he has gained wisdom
in the in the Rocky Balboa on Laurie
yeah I think he's not playing it up as
much as he got he sobered up for being
so punch-drunk yeah mark Riley that's
not gonna be bridging those spies in 30
years
yeah the real winner mark Rylance yeah
respected character actor
I wonder what bridge of spies for would
be like because I'd watch that go it
have rocketed we go back across the
bridge okay guys I hope you'll come back
next week because we've got a delightful
holiday treat for you so many things to
choose from but we think you picked the
perfect size yeah a little one and
that's Joestar that's tomorrow suppose J
Gilbert see you next week
have a good one
you